this capsule we will see examples
independence that can be
modeled with networks then bédié
we saw previously how to calculate
the marginal and joint probabilities
and since a policy conditioned
its joint productivity ratio
we are therefore able to calculate
any probabilities
conditional
now what we are going to see is
examples of conditional policies
that can be simplified and between
others we will see examples
of independence sometimes conditional
sometimes a priori into variables that
are modeled by bezy networks on
will see three different examples
first example we're going to watch we're going
to be interested in the relationship of dependency
spending between
where we have a grandparent who is the
godfather 2 1 and who is the parent of a
child he will be interested in the
relationship between a grandparent and a
child is in this case also in a
Vézien network where we have a community
so we only have the big parent and
the child will be independent
conditionally to the parents so if
we observe the godfather the grandparent and
the child will be independent then a
example of a relationship like this
to our graph here it is variable
here that form a great relationship
parents parents kids so this is a
examples that we could have
in 6 mallarmé people or burglaries to
money take the example burglaries
alarm and then hardly marries in this
case also a priori so if we do not observe
not the housebreaking soul and marry adèle
are going to be dependent and so we can see
his instrument due to the fact that
burglaries will influence the
distribution of alarms
so what kind of value to the man is going
take it presumably given
burglaries are barry burglaries that
will change
and then alarm will change the
distribution of my life so because of
his ally
a burglary addiction and marie
if we do not observe there
burglaries and marie call go
become independent so we will observe
if we remember the definition
of independence conditionally too
if they are helped by the anp
conditioning it means that the
marry probability calls knowing
alarm and burglaries will be reduced to
the probability that mayor calls his
luck only to the soul and so between
others his opinion to calculate his office that
means that we only need to
this probability there because of
independence and this probability there
in fact it is given here
this missile table so we see
how can it simplify calculations
certain departures from certain
conditional since we are able
Basque also to tell my son I have not
need it so I just need to
this probity I am given
directly in my peaceful network and
so we'll see why it's all true
that with an example a derivation
mathematics but basically this
what happens is that if she knew in
does in our calculation if he is not going to
intervene for the calculation of the
politics of knowing this here we will not have
no need for sites to
do this calculation is maybe a way
little more intuitive we can see that we
can interpret this as the fact that
can block the dependency path
between m
here so if we see that as if there
had a kind of path here associated
at the dependence between the two beautiful
effect of seeing a blocked vote this way
so let's do the math to make sure
this is the case that marie is
independent burglaries sacha alam
so let's do this calculation is here and
let's see if we can actually do
not need the value of
robberies which he defined by
definition this conditional part
it's just the joint parity of marie to
the burglaries soul you know by the
marginal probability of
alarm and burglaries now by
definition or forgiveness by calculation of
marginal probabilities and using the
I do not need people
call to calculate the probability
marginal so I can just ignore
this variable because his descendants
are not part of the variables observed
I have that marginal politics here it's
equal to this marginal probability
the man and I have to marginalized on the
value of 6
and then by the same reasoning I can
write the probity of a marginal mourning
of its constituents marginal probity
to raise and s but where I have to summit
on all possible values ​​of s
now i replace mme enjoy
marginalized by the product of
conditional probabilities extracted
of probability metal so I would have
took advantage of m knowing about the probability of
rising buy it's actually the
parents of these earthquake burglaries times
the politi a priori of s times the
a priori probability of burglaries and
in the same way here
I get the product of policies
conditional like that because that's that
I notice that in the products of
numerator here inside the sum
I have terms that actually do not depend
not at all 2 is too much that I have this
term there here the probability of marry
calls sacha the soul who do not depend
so I can take him out of the room
job go out it's also but we'll see
for the disclosure of these steps
necessary
so that's what I did here I
pulled out pdm bent on the sum so
I pdm this each time the sum here /
s
and now we notice here here I have
exactly in fact the same term and so
they can console themselves I have the same
factor that is a sum on ace at
numerator and the denominator and so
i'm really waiting for p2m sacha to
it's just m
sacha
and actually the reason I
could make this reduction there it's
that actually in the calculation and
marginal producer in the numerator to my
allowed to split my probity to a
part that was m sacha then another
part here that involved implied implied
never m
sorry so in fact it allowed me to
simplify in two parts a part where
I had variables that did not depend
no other part where
interact and so does it thanks to
the observation of 1
I could it is paris m of all
factors that could involve
is what made me come out of
my sister ok so that's the reason
mathematics
if you want who can I go out
mpm his charge thanks to them i'm in
finally measure to separate m
of the rest of the calculation that involves this is
more than a few that implies it's good
here he is at this camp it's bound
with what we find at the denominator
long thanks to that I can reduce pdm
sacha here by pdm knowing cardon
second example of independence can
to be modeled putting between two
children given the godfather so I
one by one
I have outbuildings with two children
but I find that his two children there
are going to be independent if the parent is
observed so we have the example of
of invasion three variables 3 us in a
network beziers here I have the alarm
who has two children I call it started
barely people call me and marry
call here are going to be addicted to
priori it is something that we can
demonstrate but as we will see if
I observe the parent who has the soul
well they will become independent
that is to say that the calculation for example
of the probity of husband sacha alarm and
I'm going to be reduced to calculating
the politi de marie calls knowing
only to what is given to me yet
once by my table to enjoy here
so it simplifies the calculation of a
conditional that involved before I
calls for a probability calculation that
is that I call so marie calls
were the places on appeal sacha to
the soul and did it again but if
we see dependence as existence
of a path in these two variables or one
could say that alarm is blocking the
path of dependence between people
call and marry call reason the
mathematical derivation of this example
there then again did not speak was
conditional is the probability
marginal that involves what got me
green query variable for
which I want someone to enjoy
given what is observed so
so it's because if the producti
marginal but ras holy land and that
all these variables to divide by the
marginal probity only of the variables
on which one still conditions a
times I can reduce the calculation I can
rewrite the calculation is marginal like
a summation on probabilities that
involves more variables the variables
that I can not eliminated in that if
in fact it turns out I have to summit
on s is sure it is so on earthquake and
burglaries because in that six
burglaries as descendants
some of the variables that are
involved in my calculation the variables
who was observing same thing for 6
so I have to sum explicitly on the
value and by the same reasoning
I get
this calculation for marginal probity on
alarm and jean-paul only at
denominator then of that I can
rewrite his acolytes is marginal the
com or spouses as a product of
conditional the conditional ones defined
in my bezier network so i have
expects the probability of jan aps h at the
mpt times the mayor's probity call that
it's not his by adam and coming the
probability actually here rather than
describe this part locality of calabria
sacha earthquake and burglaries times the
practice messi tweet just to keep the
marginal in full since as we go
see your disappears so this kit has
observed here is that among others I
can take this probability of the
probity of marriage calls it challenge and
put it in front of the sum since
it does not involve values ​​are not
involved are constant in relation to
the summation on the different values
of earthquakes and burglaries and so
i actually get to enjoy marie
call sacha alam once everything was
here sow on the test of other terms
that I did not go out because I could have
come out end here too
but it's not important for the
derivation actually from this
level what I observe is that I
when it is related to the numerator and
denominator the factors that corresponds
at the sums sure is sure so this is
once again I get the probity of
husband sacha alarm only so I have
managed to not use the value of
game barely ok and again what
did not allow me to do that that's
precisely the fact that by observing
alarm
the probability sure I call and on
marie calls breaks down into two
different factors so that I have
could detach them and the part in this case
which depends on both
I call your actually when is read by
the calculations that are made at the level of
denominator finally a third
example the relationship between two parents
given their children and we
also builds that we have a single child
in two a year so we have a relationship
like that so here it's going to be a little
different
both parents will be independent
but if the child and not observed ok so
if the child is observed they are going to be
dependent but if the child is not
observed the both parents will become
independent is an example of a
relationship of this style here here between so
the three random variables the three
void who here then actually in
this example the burglary and earthquake has
priori they are independent to do one
saw that if we want to calculate the
marginal probability gives some
variables we can ignore all dummies
whose descendants are not part of
variables in question variables
observed so if that would mean too
that I could if I wanted to calculate the
probability of burglaries and earthquake I
could united would have all these
variables also since their
descendants by this compromise in Cambrai
agenais 6 and then good if I break down
profile t marginal the aa
the product of the extreme policies of
Belgian tables is actually the
probability of these times the probability
why because it's up to the boxes
per year then s not opposing so
actually the probability of between
and it's between burglaries and earthquake
breaks down into a product that is not
it's just right
just cambria just two sites so
that a priori are indeed dependent
however they will become addicted if
I observe alarm and that means it means
that the probability of burglaries sacha
alarm and earthquake is not simple and
reliable it is not possible for
if I watch to the soul of Thursday will say I have
no need for the value of earthquakes and that
as we will see it is due to the fact that
the probability of alarming his luck and and
she knowing burglaries and 6 she
is not simplified and because we're going
having to introduce ended in our
calculations and that it is not possible to
separate the contribution of c is from s
wants to get that they are now linked
together they are now dependent
in the calculation of the productivity
burglaries knowing alarmed earthquake so
in this case if we see that as
pathways of dependence between
variables that we will try to block
but in fact in this case also the fact
not to know alarm
that's what will block the path between
burglaries and site
so if we see exactly
specifically in mathematics
why are we addicted
if we look at the soul well again a
times a conditional policy that
is a marginal probability ratio and
so the probability of self here is fine
to be the probability of rising knowing and
this is the probability of s
that's it for the t2 so
actually it's marginal profit there
to calculate it I can ignore the
children here they die explains business
the product of the conditionals in question
to know how to enjoy the alarms his hunt
and sometimes the politics of
burglaries knowing his godfather there
has no parents so it's just the
death same thing for pes and there we
note here this term the seals man
set s etc and it's not possible
so that's the term there is not the
gambling product on a term that depends
of these just a term that depends on
so it's because of it will never
possible to separate them
then two
to eliminate the part that just exceeds
of these to get a part that is
not just vice versa so that's
because of them specifically sounds the
mathematics does that we have a
dependence between both parents
burglary and earthquake and give them
child with a blade